Wells Fargo shares climbing after hours
after the bank announces John Stumpf
will step down from his posts as CEO and
chairman effective immediately the
company is named president Tim Sloan to
replace him
as CEO and Steven Sanger becomes the
bank's new chairman the move comes amid
a public outcry over the revelation that
Wells Fargo employees have opened
millions of bank accounts for customers
who didn't request them I want to bring
in our Bloomberg News reporter taking
Campbell now for more so they can first
of all Stumpf is the guy who led Wells
Fargo through the financial crisis what
do you make of this particular
leadership shake-up what does it mean
that's a very good question we sort of
saw this coming in September the CFPB
announced 185 million dollar settlement
with Wells Fargo over unauthorized
opening
knowledge or approval and so you know
the pressure has been mounting on John
Stumpf so at this point what is the real
damage here to Wells Fargo
you know how are customers taking this
news of course John Stumpf has been in
the hot seat for the last several months
now but is this really having an impact
all the way down the chain it's a good
question we we haven't seen much of that
Wells Fargo will report earnings on
Friday and we're hoping to learn a bit
more about whether customers are leaving
the bank or sort of picking up and
moving to competitors so far from what
we've been hearing not a lot of that is
happening so it's not clear to us how
much of this has affected the bottom
line it's worth saying that some clients
have withdrawn from Wells Fargo Chicago
Illinois California governments have
have said that they no longer are doing
business with the bank on some some
transactions so it is starting to hurt a
little bit but it doesn't look like a
lot yet it'll be interesting to see how
this plays out over the longer term I
mean another take has
that the bank has emerged fairly
unscathed they paid 185 million dollar
fine they clawed back sixty million
dollars from executives you know what do
you make of that take that it really
hasn't hurt them that much yeah it's
when this initially came out I think a
lot of people looked at the size of the
fine and looked at the amount of money
you know fees that the bank charged
customers it was like two and a half
million and said oh this is a small
thing but it's sort of built on itself
Washington DC got involved lawmakers got
involved and they they brought Stumpf
down to DC for not one but two hearings
first in front of the Senate then in
front of the House Financial Services
Committee so it's it's sort of picked on
picked up a life of its own and and
built on itself and the scrutiny and the
pressure on Stumpf really just has been
building